THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANKLE.
REMEMBER AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
LOCKDOWN WHEN I WARNED YOU ABOUT
HOW THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
ALLIES IN THE MEDIA WOULD TRY TO
USE THE EXCUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
TO KEEP THE ECONOMY CLOSED AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE AND THEN VOICED
A NEW NORMAL ON US?
>> AS A SOCIETY, JUST FORGET
ABOUT SHAKING HANDS, WE DON’T
NEED TO SHAKE HANDS.
>> EVERYTHING THAT COMES IN THE
HOUSE, I WIPE IT DOWN.
>> IT’S JUST AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FOLKS OUT
THERE.
>> WILL WILL RETURN TO NORMAL?
I DON’T THINK WE RETURNED TO
NORMAL.
>> COME ON, AFTER THE PAST 14
DAYS, THAT’S BASICALLY ALL OUT
THE WINDOW.
OVER THE WEEKEND IN L.A. AND
PHILADELPHIA WE HAD HUGE CROWDS.
BEFORE THAT WIDESPREAD RIOTS AND
WE HAD WIDESPREAD LOOTING.
SO MUCH FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING.
MEANWHILE, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ARE STILL LIVING IN DEMOCRATS
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA,
VIRGINIA, ILLINOIS, MICHIGAN.
THEY ARE STILL STANDING ON THOSE
STUPID RED DOTS OUTSIDE THE
HARDWARE STORE, DON’T YOU LOVE
THOSE, THE ARROWS AT THE
GROCERY STORE, RIDICULOUS.
AND THE LEFT, SEEING HOW
COMPLIANT SO MANY AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN IS NOW ONTO THE NEW NEW
NORMAL, OKAY?
SO UNDER THIS NEW NEW NORMAL,
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO AN OPINION
THAT CONFLICTS WITH OR CALLS
INTO QUESTION ANY ASPECT OF
THEIR CAMPAIGN TO DESTABILIZE
AMERICA THROUGH BULLYING AND
VIOLENCE.
JUST ASK THE EDITOR OF THE
"PHILADELPHIA INQUIRER," WHO WAS
FIRED FOR THE SIN OF THIS
HEADLINE, BUILDINGS THAT ARE
TOO.
AT LEAST HE ONLY LOST HIS JOB.
WHEN YOU PHYSICALLY DEFEND YOUR
BUSINESS OR HOME, YOU COULD END
UP LIKE DAVID DORN, LEFT TO DIE
ON THE GROUND.
HE WAS ALLEGEDLY MURDERED BY
THIS MAN.
THERE ARE NO TELEVISED MEMORIALS
PLANNED FOR THE CAPTAIN, AT
LEAST THAT I KNOW OF.
IN THIS NEW, NEW NORMAL, IF YOU
LOSE YOUR BUSINESS TO LOOTING OR
FIRE, WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
EMPATHIZE WITH THOSE WHO CARRIED
IT OUT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DO, THAT
DEMONSTRATES A HIGHER
RECOGNITION OF YOUR PRIVILEGE.
AND IN THIS NEW, NEW NORMAL,
IT’S PERFECTLY ACCEPTABLE TO
ASSUME THE WORST MOTIVES ON THE
PART OF ANYONE DOESN’T REPEAT
THE PROGRESSIVE MANTRA DOES.
>> A FRIEND OF MINE POSTED
SOMETHING WITHOUT POSTING
ANYTHING ABOUT
#BlackLivesMatter >> THAT YOU
CAN’T HELP YOURSELF BUT SPEAK UP
UP.
>> WHITE SILENCE IS INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL.
IT’S NOT NEUTRAL.
IT ACTS LIKE A WEAPON.
IT’S NOT EVEN SILENT.
IT SPEAKS VOLUMES, RIGHT?
>> Laura: SO YOU GET IT,
YOU’LL BE FORCED TO REPEAT AFTER
THEM, OR ELSE.
AND INSPIRED BY AL SHARPTON’S
LONG HISTORY OF SHAKING DOWN
CORPORATE AMERICA, THEY’RE KNOWN
TO DEMANDING THAT BUSINESSES
WRITE FAST TRACKS OR RISK
BRANDED INSENSITIVE AT BEST,
RACIST AT WORST.
AND WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING HOW THE
MONEY WILL BE SPENT, FEARFUL
WEALTHY ELITES ARE FALLING ALL
OVER THEMSELVES TO APPEAR THE
MOST WOKE.
>> THE OFFENSIVE FROM THE LAST
WEEK EXCRETED URGENCY
PARTICULARLY IN VIEW OF THE
RACIAL INJUSTICES THAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
WORK AND LIVE.
WE ALL NEED TO DO MORE.
AGAIN, THOSE ARE COMMENTS FROM
BRIAN MOYNIHAN, THE CHAIRMAN AND
CEO AT BANK OF AMERICA ON THIS
NEW COMMITMENT THAT THEY ARE
ANNOUNCING A BILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONAL OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS.
>> Laura: JPMORGAN CEO
JAMIE DIMON EVEN WENT TO A LOCAL
BRANCH TO TAKE ANY AND
SOLIDARITY.
BUT WILL THE MONEY REALLY BY THE
PROTECTION?
I GUESS UNTIL THE NEXT ROUND OF
DEMANDS, WHICH OF COURSE IS ANY
MINUTE NOW, WE WILL FIND OUT.
BUT THE SUBJUGATION AND SELF
HUMILIATION THAT WE’VE SEEN OVER
THE PAST WEEK IS TRULY
NAUSEATING.
IF YOU THOUGHT THE PERFORMANCE
ACTIVISM OF WHITE LIBERALS
DRAMATICALLY DROPPING TO THEIR
KNEES, FIST IN THE AIR, WASN’T
BAD ENOUGH, WELL, YOU ARE BASELY
MISSED THE NEW TREND.
FOOT WASHING STATIONS FOR
ACTIVISTS.
AND YES, THEY ARE MANNED BY
LIBERALS WITH ALMOST A RELIGIOUS
ZEAL.
AND DON’T THINK OF HAVING A D
NEXT TO HER NAME, EVEN IF YOU’RE
A FAR LEFT DEMOCRAT.
DON’T THINK THAT’S ENOUGH TO
SAVE YOU IN THIS NEW, NEW
NORMAL.
THE PAJAMA BOY MAYOR OF
MINNEAPOLIS FOUND THAT SOME OF
HIS NEW FRIENDS IN THE RIOT IN
PROTEST BUSINESS WEREN’T SO
FRIENDLY AFTER ALL.
>> JACOB FREY, WE HAVE A "YES"
OR "NO" QUESTION FOR YOU.
YES OR NO, WILL YOU COMMIT TO
DEFUNDING MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> GET THE DASH OUT OF HERE
!
[CROWD CHANTING "GO HOME JACOB"]
>> Laura: I ALMOST FELT SORRY
FOR HIM.
WATCH THE MEDIA OPERATES IN THIS
NEW, NEW NORMAL.
EVER SO GENTLY TIPTOEING AROUND
MARXISTS MASQUERADING AS
HUMANITARIANS.
>> DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THE
WORD "DISMANTLE" OR POLICE FREE
ALSO MAKE SOME PEOPLE NERVOUS TO
FOR INSTANCE, WHAT IF IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT MY HOME IS
BROKEN INTO?
WHO DO I CALL?
>> YES, I MEAN, I HEAR THAT LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM A LOT OF MY
NEIGHBORS AND I KNOW -- AND
MYSELF TOO AND I KNOW THAT COMES
FROM A PLACE OF PRIVILEGE.
>> Laura: I GUESS YOU’RE
SUPPOSED TO CALL THE WHITE
PRIVILEGE HOTLINE.
I WASN’T CLEAR ON THAT.
IF THERE WAS VIRTUALLY NO
FOLLOW-UP TO THAT MORONIC
ANSWER, BY THE WAY.
THIS LUNACY IS GAINING TRACTION
ACROSS AMERICA IN LIKE A DOZEN
OTHER MAJOR U.S. CITIES.
THAT SEEMED TO AGREE THAT
WORRYING ABOUT HOME INVASION IS
REALLY JUST -- IT’S RACIST.
FROM L.A. TO NEW YORK, MAYORS
AND CITY COUNCILS ARE LOOKING TO
STRIP FUNDS AWAY FROM POLICE AND
THEN TO REALLOCATE THEM TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
PRESUMABLY, THEY THINK THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR DON’T NEED
PROTECTION FROM CRIMINALS OF ALL
COLORS AND ETHNICITIES, OR IS IT
THAT THEY DON’T DESERVE
PROTECTION IN ORDER FOR GUILT
RIDDEN LIBERALS TO FEEL
SUPERIOR?
I DON’T KNOW.
IT BAFFLES THE MIND.
THIS LUNACY IS EVEN GETTING
SUPPORT IN CHICAGO, WHICH OVER
THE PAST TWO WEEKS SINCE THE
KILLING OF GEORGE FLOYD HAS HAD
AT LEAST 48 MURDERS AND EVEN
MORE SHOOTINGS.
THE OVERWHELMING SHARE OF THE
VICTIMS WERE AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
WHEN WE DID OUR TWO TOWN HALLS
IN CHICAGO, WE FOUND THAT THE
PEOPLE THERE WANTED MORE POLICE
PRESENCE, NOT LESS.
>> WON’T THAT MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE THEM OR UNDER SIEGE, OR
YOU’RE SAYING IT WILL MAKE THEM
FEEL SAFER?
>> IT WILL MAKE THEM FEEL SAFER.
>> WE NEED PROGRAMS THAT WE USED
TO HAVE ON THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT-LIKE OFFICER
FRIENDLY, THE EXPLORER SCOUTS.
TAKE THE YOUTH, GIVE THEM
SOMETHING TO DO.
WHEN I WORKED, 29 YEARS,
EVERYBODY THAT KNEW ME KNEW I
WAS A GOOD COP.
>> Laura: THIS CONFIRMS WHAT A
RECENT POLL FOUND, DESPITE CALLS
BY ACTIVISTS AND PROTESTERS TO
DEFUND POLICE DEPARTMENT’S,
CLOSE TO TWO-THIRDS, 65% OPPOSE
CUTTING POLICE FORCE FUNDING.
JUST 16% OF DEMOCRATS AND 15% OF
REPUBLICANS SUPPORT THAT IDEA.
ALSO OF NOTE IS THE RECENT
MONMOUTH BALL.
CHECK IT OUT, WHICH FOUND THAT
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS, OVERALL
SATISFACTION WITH LOCAL POLICE
HAS INCREASED AMONG BLACK
AMERICANS FROM 50% AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT SATISFIED IN 2015 TO
72% NOW.
SO IS THIS PUSH FOR A NEW, NEW
NORMAL REALLY, REALLY ABOUT
EQUAL PROTECTION, EQUAL
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL?
WELL, LISTEN TO THE CRIES OF
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS LIKE THIS.
>> USE A BLACK LIVES MATTER.
WHY DON’T YOU CHOKE ME, I’M
BLACK?
LOOK WHAT YOU DID TO MY STORE.
I GOT -- TELL ME BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
YOU’RE LYING!
>> Laura: WELL, IF BLACK LIVES
LIKE HERS WERE REALLY THE FOCUS,
WE WOULD ALL, ALL OF US KNOW HER
NAME.
CELEBRITIES WOULD FLOCK TO HER
STORE AND THOSE OF THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS AND HELP THEM REBUILD AND
PROTECT THEM FROM FUTURE HARM.
LOOK, AS WE’VE SAID MANY TIMES
ON THIS PROGRAM, THE KILLING OF
MR. FLOYD WAS AN ABSOLUTE
ASSAULT ON HUMANITY.
AND THE USE OF HIS DEATH TO RUN
A PROXY CAMPAIGN FOR A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE, I DON’T CARE IF IT
WAS A DEMOCRAT THIS TIME, IT
WOULD BE A REPUBLICAN SOME OTHER
TIME, IT’S A TRANSPARENT INSULT
TO OUR INTELLIGENCE.
JUST LIKE WANTING US TO BELIEVE
THAT A HEAVILY EDITED INTERVIEW
BY CBS OF JOE BIDEN TONIGHT
MEANS ANYTHING SIGNIFICANT.
BIDEN CLAIMED HE DID NOT APPROVE
OF THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
DEMANDS TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
>> NO, I DON’T SUPPORT DEFUNDING
THE POLICE.
I SUPPORT CONDITIONING FEDERAL
AID TO POLICE BASED ON WHETHER
OR NOT THEY MEET CERTAIN BASIC
STANDARDS OF DECENCY AND
HONORABLE THIS AND IN FACT ARE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE THEY CAN
PROTECT THE COMMUNITY AND
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: HONORABLE MISS.
THE POOR GUY IS NOT CAPABLE OF
DOING ALONG FOR INTERVIEW
WITHOUT SERIOUS LAPSES IN
THOUGHTS AND FOCUS.
YET WE ARE TO BELIEVE HE IS
GOING TO KEEP THE COUNTRY FROM
BURNING DOWN ONCE THE BLM AND NT
FOR FOLKS REALLY START ISSUING
ULTIMATUMS?
I DON’T THINK SO.
JOE THOUGH, LET’S GET
STRAIGHTER, HE’S HOPING THAT THE
CAMPAIGN WILL REALLY JUST BE
2008 ALL OVER AGAIN.
>> YOU DON’T HAVE TO ACCEPT WHAT
WAS CONSIDERED NORMAL BEFORE.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO ACCEPT THE
WORLD AS IT IS.
YOU CAN MAKE IT INTO THE WORLD
BUT IT SHOULD BE AND COULD BE.
YOU CAN CREATE A NEW NORMAL, ONE
THAT IS FAIRER AND GIVES
EVERYBODY OPPORTUNITY AND TREATS
EVERYONE EQUALLY AND BUILD
BRIDGES BETWEEN PEOPLE INSTEAD
OF DIVIDING THEM.
>> Laura: NOW WAIT A SECOND, I
COULD HAVE SWORN THAT HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
SO SHOULD WE CONSIDER ONLY THE
PAST THREE AND A HALF YEARS IS
NOT NORMAL?
WHY DID PRESIDENT OBAMA SOLVE
ALL THESE PROBLEMS IF HE KNOWS
WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY, BECAUSE
THESE ISSUES ARE REALLY
COMPLICATED.
NO ONE WANTS TO LIVE IN A POLICE
STATE AND NO ONE WANTS TO LIVE
IN A RACIST STATE.
ON THE HARD LEFT SUGGESTS
OTHERWISE, THEY’RE LYING.
AND THEY INSULT THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO WORK
HARD AND LIVE IN PEACE ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY AND THAT’S HOW THEY
WANT TO LIVE IN THE FUTURE.
THIS IS A GREAT NATION FILLED
WITH GOOD PEOPLE.
IF THERE ARE A RACIST POLICE,
THEY SHOULD BE FIRED.
IF THERE ARE ABUSIVE POLICE,
THEY SHOULD BE CRIMINALLY
PROSECUTED.
BUT THE LEFT A POSTHUMOUS BIG
IDEA OF DEFUNDING THE POLICE
WILL LEAD TO A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN PAIN, SUFFERING AND DEATH.
THEY DON’T CARE.
ALTHOUGH MOST AMERICANS, THEY
DO.
THAT’S WHY PRESIDENT OBAMA
DIDN’T PUSH FOR IT.
THAT’S WHY DEMOCRATS LIKE
NANCY PELOSI ARE AFRAID TO VOTE
FOR IT.
THAT’S WHY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL NEVER STAND FOR IT.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE IS A
LUDICROUS POSITION THAT SHOULD
NEVER BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
BUT TOO MANY DEMOCRATS HAVE
SHOWN THAT THEY CANNOT BE
TRUSTED TO STAND UP FOR
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS AGAINST
CRIMINALS WITH A PURPOSE.
AND COME NOVEMBER, MILLIONS OF